[Musik]
ich möchte ihnen die geschichte von
georg erzählen georg trennt sich von
seiner partnerin weil er wie er sagt
seine lügen nicht mehr aushält er kann
nicht mehr damit leben dass er mit
seiner partnerin eine gute beziehung
führt sie gern hat sich ihr verbunden
fühlt aber
beim geschlechtsakt beim sex mit seiner
partnerin gibt es einen punkt an dem er
nicht ohne fantasien an jungs seine
erregung halten bzw ein orgasmus
auslösen kann georg held dieses lügen
nicht mehr aus das hat er sich nicht
ausgesucht
betroffen sind nicht schuld an den
sexuellen gefühlen aber
verantwortlich für das sexuelle
verhalten
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich habe mir im moment sammler einfach
für mich
und normal der prozess oder der verlauf
der kopf
der menschen war jetzt ein grund mit
einer ganzen palette und dort zusammen
drehen wo problematisch sind
sexuelle präferenz wo gewöhnlich wo
ich emotional mit kann nachvollziehen
monika egli alge war eine der ersten in
der schweiz die menschen mit einer
pädophilie präventive therapie anbot
damit sie nicht täter und weniger kinder
opfer werden heute trifft sie pascal
kritik
will krumme ja willkommen es ist dem
sender kenntnis kam dass sie das sind wo
sie sind
das ist schon was sie und ich konnte
steht mit seinen wurzeln gibt aber mit
sunny dabei ist
und dann habe ich mich sagt sie auch
später wieder in einem boot verliert
standard sie wie nie sondern immer nur
zanni dornick märkte stoffhose pascal
würde eigentlich gerne offen über seine
situation sprechen sein gesicht zeigen
seinen richtigen namen nennen aus angst
vor reaktionen ist das aber nicht
möglich alle betroffenen in diesem film
zeigen wir daher anonymisiert und mit
fremder stimme
vor 42 jahren ist es schon schwierig sie
wo ich die erkenntnis kommen dass ich
bin was ich bin ich verliebe mich in
kurve zwischen 7 und 13 ich verliere
mich nur alles andere ist aber ich finde
nur schön ich hätte es aber nicht der
wunsch mit mainburg 62 wieder phantasie
show aber es ist fantasie für mich ganz
klar dass es auch fantasie beliebt
pascal ist laut eigenen angaben nie
täter geworden das heißt er hat keine
delikte begangen keine sexuellen
übergriffe an kindern und auch keine
missbrauchs abbildung konsumiert im
volksmund unter dem begriff
kinderpornografie bekannt
pascal ist heute 30 jahre alt er lebt
allein und arbeitet in einem
handwerklichen beruf seit 14 jahren geht
der regelmäßig to monika engel
gentherapie
bezeichnet sich als kinderschützer
des spardrucks oder nein ich finde das
überhaupt eine
paradoxie handcreme der eigentliche kern
nun ja wie mir ist ganz klar ich kann
das nicht aber ich wette mit kremling
tour für mich und vor ich trinke lieber
das bier oder durchschlafen statt des
kinns missbrauchen
es ist natürlich
so aber ich habe gelernt dass ich zwei
herrschen kann ich sagen dass ich viel
volk wie machen sie das überhaupt sich
beherrschen
angesehene sexualität und drückt ja das
ist vollkommen der menschlichen stimme
aber wurde nach 40 jahren ist es
natürlich leichter das zeige es ist ein
prozess seine sexualität special sowie
das andere haben können es gibt sechs
befriedigung was ich will kriegs einzige
feld und findet sich damit ab und man
nimmt außenteile
was fällt ihnen meister gefehlt hat so
mancher
chrome ist will ich weiß nicht was ich
kann hier richtig das gefühl erlebt ich
habe zwar meine freundin kam aber das
ist sexy und hatte auch keiner
weiß wirklich nicht richtig was los ist
wir sehen mit der betroffenen begleitete
gefährden das bleibt immer thema wie er
denn überhaupt und es gibt fast
kriege die möglichkeit der wirklich
glücklich zu unterstellen mit sexualität
sondern was ist
da ist zukunft
aller männer 40 von kindern sexuell
angezogen sie haben eine pädophilie oder
die expertinnen sagen eine präferenz
besonderheit auf den kindlichen körper
davon gehen aktuelle forschungen aus
mindestens jeder hundertste man also
auch frauen sind betroffen wie vielen
weiß man noch nicht so genau auch nicht
wie sich die sexuelle präferenz genau
entwickelt pädophil sein heißt aber
nicht automatisch täter sein oder täter
werden
die präferenz da ich mit verbote da
haben wir junge störe das hat man oder
man hat nomura das wertfrei aloe
fantasien und gedanke ist nicht verboten
fantasie und gedanken
seniorenheim selber und schaltet man ihm
an
sobald sie eine handliche gott wird
problematisch
sobald die präferenz besonderheit
verhalten hat also über sap zum beispiel
auch neue klinische ried grenze verletzt
dänisches verbote und dennis illegal kai
delikt ist oberstes ziel wir verurteilen
die liegt mir
vorteile daten und zwar alle die haltung
ist völlig klar aber
personen persönlichkeit eines menschen
die ihr name respect for peace in
empfang war man sehr würdigend ist der
schritt ist und
dass man katholik gemacht das finde ich
bin stark
wer sich traut die telefonnummer
monatsmitte und dort zeige
ich glaube ich brauche hilfe
monika ideal geleitet ein forensisches
institute ihr therapeutenteam behandelt
oft menschen mit einer pädophilie
die arbeit mit menschen mit einer
präferenz besonderheit für den
kindlichen körper ist anspruchsvoll für
die therapeutinnen infor ion
das macht das machen auch schultern
verteile das mache ich mache für
persönlich verhalte werde so dass
philipp hielt seine größte aber ich
mache zu wenig ist darüber und durch die
erfahrung steht man ganz andere sicher
ganz anders wenn man direkt kontakt hat
mit den erhöht also man hat damals das
gefühl man sitzt da oder und so stirbt
ist ein persönlicher freund hook das
ganz anders und das wird kein mensch
verstehen
sind geschlossene abo
karten mit sicherungs melde und sei ja
alles problem ich merke ich stehe
und die reise gemacht
[Musik]
trifft mich jetzt mit dem ball und ich
kann die kennengelernt in der krise
situation wenn er ihre gestanden hat was
in die situation ist und für mich
persönlich ist auch
anspruchsvolle situation sie wie genau
die situation für angehörige so
besonders ist und so emotional aber
intensiv
[Musik]
auf einer seite immer so es zählt man
den boden unter die füße weg und das ist
wirklich
super gespielt was rund oben ist absolut
nicht kann mega festmesse brille für
mich wirklich gewaltsame brauchen im
moment will ich meinen mann
kennengelernt wo ich mir immer gewünscht
haben sehr fürsorglich sehr liebevoll
zärtlich
aber es ist so jetzt nimmt mir das weg
jetzt ist das jetzt das baby will dass
gott begonnen beides dass gott gar nicht
wir haben ja eine tier präferenzen und
frau lieber wo ältere schon sehen es ist
mit so viel eine angst verbunden warum
sie dann mit mir zusammen war eigentlich
jüngere frauen
liebte mich dann überhaupt aber dank
schnellem sex und das sind ja ganz viele
sachen wollen dann innerhalb von
sekunden und hopfen und es hat
wahnsinnig weh tue sich unbeschreiblich
mache das ja gar nicht sagte
martin ist um die 30 seine partnerin
christina einige jahre älter martin hat
eine nicht ausschließliche hebe philly
dh der früh pubertäre mädchen körper
erregt ihn allerdings nicht nur er kann
auch den körper einer erwachsenen frau
anziehen finden sich in sie verlieben
sie und klanglos eingesetzte mit
ja und es geht richtig sie punkt also da
gibt es einfach nicht wo mir ist erst
mal gesehen hat hat einfach gemacht und
das dünnste abduschen aber es ist
einfach es ist wirklich es hat
xxxx gefühlt conny waßmuth am anfang
sagen sondern ich muss ihre ziele zu mir
keine lehre und ich muss vertrauen sie
das wenn ich das sage ich weiß dass die
bombe platzt und dass sie damit gar
kursieren und die sich ab alter egal was
aus der beziehung wird das ist das
grundvertrauen com user haben
ist sehr schmal dass die seine partnerin
zeigen es sind mehrere partnerschaften
buga möglichen grund wie es nicht
geschafft von zum opfer darüber rede ich
habe gewusst wie ich das weiterhin für
druck kann ich nur sagen will sich nicht
lästig wenn man sohnes chamis atompartei
wohnt das gar nicht als auch ohne
philipp aber der bezirk den flügen aus
rhede und da nicht gewusst dass wir für
drucke dom ist für mich klar sie war
nicht nur schafe zu mir das sagen haben
und ich spürte irgendetwas ist und
entweder uns jetzt auf den tisch oder
ich kann so eine wetterlage wenn ich
merke dass ich muss einfach gespürt ich
weiß nicht warum
oder kurz kaputt wie sie es mit ja und
wenn ich sage dass im islam zerstöre die
grundlage ist es wird ein suizid gern
tusk und seiner sexuellen präferenz für
pubertierende mädchen geht martin nach
er wird straffällig
das habe ich relativ früh gemerkt mit 17
18 dass es im rückblick bliebt was ich
begehre das auch nicht ein problem könne
mit mir mittragen aber irgendwann ist
fast so volk sie dass ich den vierten
und zwar nicht internet pornographie
konsumiert im illegalen bereich
bei der hälfte aller männer mit einer
pädophilie kommt es im laufe ihres
lebens zu einer straftat das heißt sie
begehen einen sexuellen übergriff oder
konsumieren missbrauchs abbildung laut
studien erlebt jedes fünfte mädchen und
jeder dreizehnte bub einmal im leben
einen sexuellen übergriff
die hälfte der täter ist nicht pädophil
[Musik]
hunt siemers bedürfnis in realität ist
dass arminia kam was ich wirklich die
moralisch sie täterin hat das tier zu
erklären mir hat's wiener virtuelle welt
konnte real vor gut fünf jahren wird
martin verhaftet kommt für ein halbes
jahr in untersuchungshaft
danach in therapie straffällig seither
nicht mehr geworden kurz nach dem
gefängnis lernt der christina kennen und
lieben nach gut zehn monaten erzählt er
ihr alles über seine präferenz das
gefängnis
ich will sich nach clark sieht das event
zusammen bliebe ich glaube dass ich
relativ schnell ganz ehrlich einfach
genial
slips und der das träumen nicht einfach
beenden es ist nicht gesagt wie das
schönste sondern es hat schon zieht buch
das man sich wieder her kenne lösen und
entspannen und wirklich so für mich eine
sache kann ich die beziehung
weiterführen soll wir hatten auch eine
filter über geld und hat natürlich alles
mit offizieller und mini 100 musiker vor
frage beantworte ich
werde älter wirst du das überhaupt oder
bruchstückhaft als objekt das recht eine
sexualisierte in einer normalen pc
islate also mich zieht wie sägen wurde
oder nachdem es braucht gilt also ja zu
dem zeitpunkt stabil sieht also minuten
ist ja das habe ich aber alles nicht
gewusst
dass
ich mich so wie tauchen erlöse und jetzt
nicht vom gedanken aber einfach wieder
raus ohne sexualität töne oder dafür
genieße das recht besser einfach meinem
ressort immer unsere lotterie steckt für
das andere das hat das titel braucht
aber inzwischen für möglich sagt das
stimmt für die sache mit teile
miteinander rum wo mir mit den anderen
krise und waren es ist verschiedentlich
für oli unverständlich aber mit dem raum
schlagen
[Musik]
in basel wartet die neue aufgabe für
monika egli alge
[Musik]
mercure immer wieder für die betroffenen
dass sie versucht und hilft sohle aber
die ihr nicht überkochen und der
expertenbericht für den bundesrat hat
klaro sekunde dass es ganz viel läuft
braucht für die betroffenen bis
überhaupt noch ein unterschied dass die
häufiger fahren zum beispiel wo
niedergelassene psychotherapeut
psychiater psychiaterin oder august
praxis sie ihr konto nicht helfen sind
mit
spezialisten mit kennedys mit der
thematik nicht aus
der bund hat deshalb den kantonen den
auftrag gegeben prävention angebote im
bereich präferenz besonderheit für
kinder auszubauen und sich zu vernetzen
markgraf ist direktor der klinik für
forensik der universitären
psychiatrischen kliniken basel
dankeschön
richten soll
für gruppentherapie graf gehört neben
monika egli alge in der schweiz zu den
führenden kräften bei der prävention für
pädophile
das manöver diene
ferenczy quadriga gefängnis oder ihnen
klinik grund sondern ihnen ambulanten
bereich überzeugt mich sehr möglichkeit
toll ich bin großer fan von
gruppentherapien
profilfoto wirksamkeit überzeugt und
eigentlich auch wissenschaftliche studie
ganz klar dass man muss kombiniere
gruppen in einzeltherapie und er macht
genau die gleichen erfahrungen weißt du
fakt ist dass es länger braucht bis man
motivierte gruppe ttsg rowenta einer
malgruppe sind ja dann öffnet sie sich
erstaunlich
schneller und tiefer als der einzig graf
hat für die lancierung des neuen
präventionsangebot eine fachtagung
rasiert an der auch monika egli alle
auftritte in filmen sowie die themen und
bringt
ein eintrag von 2006 schoss
gab noch den
karibikstaaten schmidt kein täter werden
und ganz früher kontakt aufgenommen
und ist ein deutlicher bildet das
deutsche präventionsangebot kein täter
werden ist vorbild für eklige und graf
im bereich prävention ist deutschland
weiter als die schweiz
die erfahrung gemacht dass ich mich nur
ein patient suizid florian dass es ist
nötig dass man den menschen helfen und
essig sinnvoll bilden so wertvoll wird
wirksam ist das ganze bringt sogar recht
liegt analogie ja ich zur situation von
platzspitz kn betroffene drogenszene
vieler jahre wo man auch sie hätten
paradigmenwechsel ist nötig weg von
rheine visionen und notabene unbedingt
braucht tarif oder brasilien ganz klar
strafen folge straftat ruhig bucht aber
das land alleine es braucht die
diagnostik und hilfestellung und dort
sieben natürlich integrieren bin froh
wenn jetzt die verschiedenen teile
angebot was er wirklich funktioniert
meiner heimat und mögliche wie es auch
mit dem lied vom netzwerk kein täter
werden muss berliner der charité durch
den standard den internationalen kann
ihn stellen es gibt ganz klare fokus auf
kontrolle und verhalten das therapieziel
keine liegt um die uhr besetzte nicht
mit trainieren kann macht ihn zum
beispiel mit fantasie tagebuch kann ich
erfahren dass sie und ich weiß wenn die
ja fatal denn gott geliebt er irgendwann
ändert simi legale berief wie kann ich
ihm als er fand dass ihr weiche stelle
das eben in illegale berichtet was mache
ich wenn in der stadt junge person
gesehene minderjährigen sexuell
ansprechen dort lernen denn die fanden
das hier einfach zur toni den schläger
oder hatte die unterbrechung
[Musik]
weeze
es freut mich außerordentlich sie hier
begrüßen zu dürfen zu neulancierung
unseres präventionsprojektes kein detail
in berlin wahrscheinlicher eine
pionierarbeit eines großen teams und
pionierin auch hier in der schweiz in
kleineren rahmen ohne kabelgewirr kennen
seit vielen jahren als praktischen
arbeit
georg war einer der ersten betroffenen
die unser angebot in anspruch genommen
hat georg hat gemäss eigenen angaben
wieder legte begangen auch keine
missbrauchs abbildungen konsumiert die
sexuelle aktivität georgs ausschließlich
mit masturbation
ausschließlich mit fantasien niemand
weiß davon immer wieder phasen der
traurigkeit immer wieder phasen der
verzweiflung und hoffnungslosigkeit es
kommen zum zieht gedanken hinzu so
intensiv dass eine hospitalisierung in
einer psychiatrischen klinik
notwendig wird und er da mit seiner
schweren depression behandelt wird das
hat er sich nicht ausgesucht liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen wenn ich
gefragt werde warum macht ihr das
eigentlich warum machst du das
dann sage ich jemals im grunde bin ich
eine kinderschutz uhr in
und dieser aspekt
dass täter arbeit prävention ist macht
mir sehr eindruck vielen dank
[Applaus]
[Musik]
franz erst mit kind und familie schafft
wo opfer erfahrungen gemacht haben und
jetzt ist für mich die möglichkeit
das angebot und das engagement wie texte
oder überhaupt übergriffes krenz
vermieden und das kinderschutz und
kabarett man kann nicht immer stärker
damit weniger übergriff gibt die
verantwortung für die übergriffe
täterschaft und mit dem opfer brutal
setzen
[Musik]
für mich im xi wann ein pädophiler also
ich sags jetzt ganz salopp kind
missbraucht dann kam der schwarze porta
fira st und rechnet für mich ist das die
sind wirklich von ihrem schärfste
verurteilt wurden das kann man später
dieses monster und ich komme gerne
können vorstellen dass er das hat ich
bedanke mich aber nicht er und plötzlich
ist hier so niveau betroffen ist von dem
was gott sowie zu sein anders haben sich
gerne vorstellen ich sage immer stammt
die die schweine gesteht die
gesellschaft um einige andere weil man
sich intensiv mit dem thema
auseinandersetzt und bereit ist sich auf
das thema und vorher geht es dir meine
und die ich so ich bin auch schon in
ihren sexy und während photonen abgelegt
und eine seite irgendein exekutionen
peter und da kann ich nicht sagen will
ich glaub mir wird merken wie wichtig
mir das thema ist um wird merke dass ich
betroffen bin und was mache ich dann ich
kann nicht sagen ich kann ja nur minimal
später fiel das kann ich nicht sagen
während diese kräfte pocono
gegeben extrovertierte treten und
gesellschaftsrechtler aber das ist nicht
so einfach wenn man irgendwo wohnt und
gut integriert ist privat und
beruflichen status hat es gott sei dank
wahrscheinlich gibt es jedem bekannten
reise aber das hat und er will
gesellschaft so urteilt als field goal
zum irgendwo es anzeichen machen oder
irgendwann mal ansprechen kann das
problem ich so viel vor also ich hab mir
rede im innenhof zieht ich habe so viele
fragen zu dem thema und die sind nun
beantwortet wurde so dass ich irgendwann
am punkt kopien und kräutern jetzt
bringe ich mich um ich mag nehme ich auf
märz um mich mit mir und deren großem
entsetzen über hätte ich fertig
und ja das ist nur viel zu erfahren und
reporter portion spielwitz verdanken
dass ich da bin
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ganz vielen der extrem
damit dass man kinder war
kann ich das verstehen
ja klar es ist schwer sie das christkind
begehren jedes kind wo bis bucht wird
egal was für ein ort das ist viel aber
das ist ein fakt dass es losgeht wo das
land und stadt die person wo dann hilft
schlecht zu machen oder zu beschimpfen
sieht man doch deine mannschaft dass sie
trotzdem nur machen glaube ich auch mit
schnauze voll von dem ganzen verein und
natur aus weil ich eigentlich ganz
normal wie aufzeigen
wo
der hund sich seit ich kann eigentlich
nie so richtig
es ist schwer mit dem concept vehicles
mit freundin weg sie zog mit frau mit
kind was sagen sie dann ja
partnerin gefunden das nützt männlich
und dann sagt es ja okay du bist noch
jung okay ich bin mit ihnen
recht jung aber ich würde einfach am
liebsten machen dazu stellt das doppel
aber mühsam
gesellschaft
stellt
kinderschänder
mehrere labour times im alltag mit der
betroffenen sehr hinderlich
will da
die betroffenen zusätzlich
belastet und mit
risiko
mindern und wirkt sondern dass
das
verleitet die betroffene änderte zu
einer weniger zins transparent sie
nominieren doppelleben zu
[Musik]
zu der gründungsversammlung vom verein
klinikums projekt in deutschland wo ja
so ist es mit projekten für die gründung
trifft sich monika egli alge mit den
verantwortlichen der universitären
psychiatrischen kliniken basel genf und
zürich
moment
bist du
bist du jetzt extra von berlin
wir schätzen das sehr
begrüße euch alle ganz herzlich und sie
leisten schon ein paar mal nach berlin
und habe einen guten austausch auffangen
können mit euch ich glaube ich das
einfach hier begleiten zu dürfen und wir
freuen uns ebenso das auch mit all
unseren erkenntnissen zu unterstützen
und simulieren kannst du kein wort zur
homepage sagen leuchten jaja die läuft
und es gibt auch ein zunehmendes
interesse
und ich habe das mit dieser logik
übernommen weil wir doch sehen dass wir
recht viele menschen haben die
angehörige sind und sich informieren
möchten sehr viele zuweiser da jetzt
auch drüber gesprochen klappt das ist
das was wir ziemlich schnell jetzt
angehen müssen würde ich dann zur wahl
auffordern und fragen wer dafür ist dass
monika egli alge das präsidium zunächst
mal übernimmt für die amtszeit von zwei
jahren
[Musik]
herzlichen glückwunsch der
gründungspräsident in das war ein
dankeschön ging dann kein täter werden
swiss gibt es ab jetzt
vielen dank und auf diesen moment würde
ich gern mit deutscher anstoßen
[Musik]
danke
denke es für die welt bedeuten immer
auch bedeuten natürlich für die schweiz
insbesondere noch die kinder und die
betroffenen menschen für die das angebot
der gedacht ist global betrachtet dann
ist eben festzustellen dass fast nichts
getan wird obwohl die zahlen sexuellen
kindesmissbrauch so hoch sind in der
welt und solche netzwerke sympatisch
leuchttürme in der welt auch die
vielleicht auch den möglichkeit sinn
oder den i dem horizont von
politikerinnen und politiker noch von
fachkräften das als baustein einer
seiner umfassenden präventionsstrategie
zu übernehmen oder adaptieren
[Musik]
ich merke einfach wie gut dass du
galibier journalisten sind oder so dass
man einfach mal mit werden über das
thema retro look vom fach ist wahr dass
unsere andere perspektiven erweckt
gesellschaft muss lernen die augen und
ohren aufzumachen und sich dem stellen
und sagen dass ich ein teil von der
gesellschaft es ist nicht schön und es
ist nicht einfach aber wir als
gesellschaft öffnet wieder aus uns
enttabuisieren denn machen mehr
opferschutz
networks kontakt
mit öffentlich darüber recht ruiniert
man sich einfach wie
gesellschaftspolitisch aber ich bin
überzeugt wenn ich sage jetzt mal offen
drüber redet sagt nach wie vor müssen
kritisch drüber reden und dort eine
mögliche verurteile das ist wichtig aber
einfach als gesellschaft offener darüber
reden und das lied mit referenzen
tankstopps sondern sage ja du hast das
es gibt genug fachstelle wonnegau und wo
inhalte zu mit der neigung bonn
ich glaube niemand mit meinem arzt dass
hunt sieht heftig dass sich das noch
andere vielleicht wenn ich alt bin aber
mit 50 muss ich mich dann eine minute
die zander ist auch wichtig sind
wie wenn sie werde aus mensch als mensch
wo das hat es ist ziel von mir dass ich
schon sagen das bin ich bin so wie ich
bin ich nicht dafür ich möchte für kein
mitleid das bringt nimmt aber dass man
mich verstaut und mir eine gotte tod
wünscht oder so
[Musik]